ベビークリス肇社長です今年も良い終わるということで私はじめ冊を今年もたくさんの
動画を撮ってきました
どうだを取ることによってものがたくさん増えましてあんな嬢僕の家は今
もので溢れかえっています
お家だけども年末なんでクリスマスなんですけどもお掃除しようかなと思いまして今回
家にあるものをたくさんメルカリで出兵していきたいとおもいます
[拍手]
だけども見てください私の家モードものものだらけで基本的に僕動画でしかもう使わ
ないねあの全部いらないと言うけど世の中には僕より必要にしてる人がいると思うんで
あのぜひこれらを出兵して一攫千金狙っていこうかなと思っております
僕ので3階の公正なんでもう1回せず見てとれずも目に入ったもので売れそうだなと
パティ年使った道具だけでねえかあ章
心そして結構みんな苦しく場所が変わったんでいろいろなモノが溢れてるよねいいなー
れ変更つっじゃあねっ
増加で見て今日帰りますねするのでそっとなんですよ
もうこういう感慨深いハイテン材
リップから入ってるんですよねっ
ベロ部分ですよ入っなぁ危ないかなぁあロスこれよりましょう一個人の星
と言ってこっちよりまこつ強がそっと欄になるず売りますこれよります
taipei
一人の技術を止めますそれじゃあさっそく出品していきましょう
スピン
写真を撮る上だと思いません普通にカメラを水やない
あっはぁ
ジャパンには休んで打っていきましょうカテゴリーは
掘りですねホビーホビースミンたりートイガンですねこれは
商品の状態目立った汚れや傷は無いですほぼ新品
ちょっとダメだいややキズやヨゴレあり商品するしようなショットガン
迷彩柄の市場のショットだんですちょっとだけ痛いです
を塗っててっる
を嫌ないた花です
そしてした後行った時にこのちょっと見ていきます
あうってるって言ってる売ってましたなんか売れてる子様もショットがあったんです
けど3,100円でくれてました
一戦ウンガー
でもなぁまぁちょっとや滑る2500円でおりますでは出費じゃあ出品
笛めちゃさえできればたとえ今とってする出兵しましたからね
明日こんな感じでどんどん出品していきましょうこれもよりますが
キル筋肉ですよこれ付けれと筋肉増強するですよね中だけで重いものだが運ぶ時に
めっちゃ楽に運べるというこれ
売りますが早速打っていきましょう
してる僕の柄も欲しいですね
あっほどー人俺なんだよなカテゴリーを
これなんだ衣類じゃないですか衣類かこれなんだ
その他多分なんですけどこれその他の外でちょっとジャッジ呼びましょう
雑誌の方はいを出す今日はそれじゃ滑ると莉乃ちゃんクマですよろしくお願います
ちょっとあの出品で分からないことがあるときように雑
だと言わせておりますよろしくお願いしますこれどういうジャンルですかね
それは
メンズですよねメンズですかはい
その他7メンズのその他ではいありがとうございいきましょうわけじゃシャレじゃな
いっ
そうヒミズでこれたぶんあんまり覚えてないんで目立った傷や汚れなし
商品名駅ルキミックなんて名前なんだっけなぁ
マッスルスーツか桐木抜くマッスルスーツ
言っていました俺も値段はアン day
みんなも使える打つ済ませる選定し読めますうわまってやばいやばい
中4万5000で売られていますそのソウル道ですねこれよこれめっちゃ高いな
ねぇねぇ自転やつで24万では20万って言われず14なんですよねちょっと初めて
13マンドゥ
楽しいんですよね
13万が一ましょう本体の売っているもの
それの価値ありますかねこれ出品しまう13万円です
準備か化粧車これ3杯目どう見ても俺だモンコレ
ブーバー頃スポットポンヌフ大丈夫でっああっ
あっております
ブースで出品していきましょう
こわいよー
でこれ動画で実際に使われてやつですか
動画がキラッ
できたこれたしか1000円ぐらいで買った気がするんだよなぁ
例にしますはれてんだよ商品状態キズやヨゴレ行き前汚れとこじゃない
全体的て状態が悪くはないんだよキズやヨゴレあり
すすめ部に帰った
確かにはれているのは呪いの仕様ですご了承ください
ok これで1000円で売りましょう
出品
[音楽]
ブーバーし決勝セーブルはつくろサティ
音リットル分の消そう水曜日たいと思います
始めちゃったかなはいここでちょっとご注意があるなぁイエローを通されたんですか
今は正規に流れても大丈夫ですけどねテスターとか
し強度とかああいうの出品数のはちょっとパネェ
ダメなんですね入るほどこれ直普通に買ったんでけど
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーブーそんなつっ
えっちょっと待ってくれてる増えているあ650円出せフォーレ
なお
11,700ルーは+38,000円
50,000これぞラーマから5万円ですよこれ
そのところそのところですよね
版円のところ29000とありがとうございますございます今ありがとうございます
日本救援これ別やすいする多分はい出品完了いたしましたーーっっいや当然を味わって
飛んだけどぞもうちょっとここまで出品したものをちょっと見られているかどうかだけ
みましょう
なんぼ冷えとかないですからね出品した商品
えっ
to do みましょうパですっ
ありがとうございますん
よくこれ洋服とかでやるテクニックですけどご自身が何センチだからこれくらいです
事態
なるほどなるほど絶海これ170くらいあるけど全然100南2線中ですかね
よし ok 内部にだろう1000円で売りたい時は
1111円ですかそうですこちら
1,111円再出品かけいたしました
もうちょい言いましょうか知ったいきましょう絶対が地下でございますここ
撮影スペースになってるで結構ものが多いんですよ見ていきましょう
持ってここにものがたくさんで難しいなぁ
あっはこれのこれウロこれスレイプニールってねれるめっちゃう夫が出る機会なんです
よ
てきただけどこれ降りますね写真でも汚れたところをちゃんと写真撮ってあげたりとか
あーなるほどなるほど
3問題値段ですねこれメルカリ相場っていうのが気にしてください
他もサイト様で打っている資格
はいと実際に取引されているか来て作っちゃうですねはいちょっと見てみますか
3245000円ぐらいかなぁ高校はちょっと汚れも目立ってるにょあー夏休みや汚れ
が目立って申し訳ない
ブーバーいますわぁどうしようかあっあんっ飼育しコール70分
いませんやばくねそれ10本入ってっとでろうかな
[音楽]
q 4 the bar チェーン40個売ります
よし
[音楽]
ポリス戦へはい
ありながら大めっちゃもれとるん
ではこちらの金額じゃあまた1本約2000がで買ったんですけども
10本セットです
長谷アップできませんありがとうございます
すっぴん鎖を致しましたピッピッっ入ってタイプだしたてくれますはいえーと今そう
ですねえっとおでんののぼりが売れたんですねー
あればすごいたんですか入れましたね30分階ですかね
でそうですよもし可能ならば外れしたそのサインなど書いたとしてもです寒いです彼と
サイン書いてあげましょう
転売をしないでくださいでこんな優れるもんなんですね
ぜひ他の方も打つの
いいのはぜひお買い求めくださいではどうぞいきましょう
いきましょうはい続いて動画でも使ったんですけどもこちらのですね
ロウソクっぽい照明唯りっ子でやりたいんですけどすごいよ買っちゃったんで
ただこの両あってもうれしいと思うんですよねこれ例えばお風呂場の周りとかに飾って
ばもうそれだけでエロい空間できますからできますたい
これで麻布の免税してのような空間
んですねじゃあなんか飛ばすかしていきましょう数
これだけですよねだから大事ですね数はちゃんと数えます
[音楽]
ポスターはクリスマスどう姿が本当本給せないですね
ああああああ
ほんと酢本舗数本というのですいやいただけますよ
たりなコーナーも怪しいになっ
[音楽]
エキサイトいいんですね使えます
られてくださいね合計300個でした
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーブー302000円 noon キュッキュロス爆安
300個1万円生きて帰る8割ですよ是非お買い物でございません
菅出品完了いたしました結構へのことが減ったか音で考えを述べるから夜のご案内して
おります
かっこいいというわけで年末に向けてたくさんが脅し出品させていただきました
ございます
声早くれてびっくりしますが十品中にこの絵をでんだそう
もうすぐ入っちゃっててこんなハイ増えるのかと思って売ろうと思った瞬間にする出品
できるので売っちゃっ使えずになってあらためて思いましたありがとうございます
結構儲かるんで全部と私ですね来年からまたし服が着れるんで
稼いだお金でラインできるような服を買おうかと思いません
ということになっておりますで何度ですね年末年始で舞台で出品するとお得な
キャンペーンがあるみたいです
そしてですねチューン2月26日から始まる明海爆買キャンペーンに頭がよいあの娘
ガーネット往路のダーウィンチェロさんと一緒にさーんか阿蘇メーカー1夏もう皆さん
が大アーチもう散っもらってなるほど
源さんが良いモノをどんどん買っていくとそればぐらいすると
そうです皆さんご参加くださいません蘇生でそのメルカでバク外なんですけどもお題が
も3人ずつ決まっておりまして私のお題が
税法形のものでございます[ __ ]がミットきた正方形のものだったらか運営が近くをの
させておいてください
ということを皆さんの参加をお待ちしておりますはせないはどんな外部からチェックし
てみてください
ちょっとこの動画が出てるときにこれでまだ売れ残ってるかわかんないんですけど
のこと言ったらぜひ買ってくださいよろしくお願いでしょうん
web を使ってな
ものかというようなものを打って a
[音楽]
じゃ
me
teame
car
あっはぁ
いやすいません
はい